c'est dans le bosquet de l'arc de
triomphe que débute le voyage un 5/6
trône celui de marguerite humeau l'une
des dix sept artistes qui composent ce
voyage d'hiver ce récit suit les
mouvements des saisons les mouvements de
la nature auquel le château de
versailles est identifié s'est toujours
montré que la création naturellement a
toute sa place au château de versailles
et qu' elle n'est en aucun cas en
opposition avec le patrimoine mais qu'au
contraire le présent et le passé se
servent de me revoir réciproque
c'est merveilleux de travailler sur le
changement de la saison et d'en faire un
symbole qui était très conscient chez
les artistes qui ont conçu le parc de
versailles
c'est l'équivalent centre un état
intérieur et un état de la nature il
fallait montrer ce qu'était la culture
compte la sculpture contemporaine dans
la diversité de ses matériaux des
installations dont on a choisi les
meilleurs artistes de générations
diverses de pays divers
une progression émotionnelle où se
mêlent la solitude mélancolique d'une
tête
esseulé celle pensé par l'artiste
néerlandais marke wenders à la sculpture
paradoxal et fragile de david altmejd
j'aime quand les choses sont pas figés
dans un moment mais plutôt qu'ils
donnent l'impression qu'ils sont tout le
temps en transformation continuelle j'ai
pris la décision de pain inquiéter
justement avec ne pas faire une
sculpture de bronze parce que c'est
c'est c'est la chose la plus évidente
quand on présente inscriptions à
l'extérieur bronze tout ça mais plutôt
de faire quelque chose de complètement
inattendu et d'utiliser des matériaux
super fragile des matériaux mixtes
colorés des oeuvres parfois évolutive
dans le temps des créations monumentales
pour voir le temps d'un hiver les
jardins d'un domaine magistrale d'un
autre oeil